hello everyone thank you emmanuel and
lauren for the beautiful introduction
we'll be beginning with the session in
10 minutes from now thank you for
joining
i would like to welcome all those
participants who have joined the session
now
we will be beginning with today's
webinar in
seven more minutes from now
and we would like to welcome you all
thank you for joining and meanwhile we
begin with today's webinar it would be
great if you could please introduce
yourself in the chat box tell us about
your educational background and your
research interests
looking forward to it thank you
a very warm welcome everyone
i would like to welcome you all to this
webinar on bioinformatics for infectious
diseases
this program is dedicated to the study
of viral diversity and its role in
epidemic infectious diseases that keep
re-emerging including zoonotic spill
over transmission between humans and the
process of viral and bacterial disease
development
the participants of the program will get
a chance to learn bioinformatics and
analyze genomic data by applying various
analysis approaches to study viral
genomes
and as a result you will learn to
understand relationships between viral
strains and haplotypes find differences
in sequence data and see the
implications for drug and vaccine design
this program will provide opportunities
to practice analyzing data to gain
hands-on experiences with curated data
sets from public domain collections
guided by experts with bioinformatics
experience and knowledge about about
virology
to introduce myself first of all my name
is sunalika ray and i'm the omislogic
community manager i'm responsible for
daily interaction with thousands of
users that are a part of a
bioinformatics community that is managed
by pine biotech
for those who are joining us for the
first time let me quickly introduce us
we are a us-based bioinformatics company
who is working with multiple academic
and commercial collaborators to develop
easy-to-use analytical tools and our
mission is to make bioinformatics more
accessible
omixlogic research-based training
programs are a result of close
collaboration between pine biotech and
numerous academic institutions that have
participated in content evaluation
curriculum review and project design
omics logic training has been completed
by over 10 000 participants from 162
countries in over 300 workshops and due
to this fast growth our team is working
with local and racial coordinators that
are helping refine the local program
logistics and leverage our online
training resources adapting them to the
needs of students and researchers around
the world
the programs follow a project-based
learning approach using research-grade
tools to analyze data from top
peer-reviewed journals the training has
been completed by six
in six different specialization tracks
which includes oncology infectious
diseases precision medicine neuroscience
data science for biomedical data and
comprehensive training on omix data
analysis
so this was about us and our motto
behind the training programs
now let's start by signing up to the
learn.oxlogic portal this educational
portal will help you get started on your
bioinformatics journey
and as a part of this program the
participants will have the access to the
omixlogic courses which includes courses
on bioinformatics precision medicine
multi-omics including genomics
transcriptomics metagenomics and
epigenomics data science that includes
bioinformatics using r and python and
the structural aspect of biology that is
chem informatics
as a part of the program you would also
have the access to the example project
of different fields which you could
learn from and replicate for your
research work
throughout the course you will be given
directions to access the t bioinfo
platform for bioinformatics processing
and analysis of transcriptomics data
the platform includes demo pipelines as
well as data management and analysis
cloud infrastructure to run
bioinformatics pipelines
so now let's go to the learn.org logic
portal and sign up quickly that will
help you go through the various
resources that our mentors will be
taking us through in today's webinar
so i request you all to please
put in the link of the porter
learn.omixlogic.com
on your laptops or if you're connected
via mobile phones
and make sure that you sign up on the
portal and have an account for yourself
to access the various resources
now those who have already created their
account on the portal can let me know by
putting in one or yes in the chat box
and others can
go through the portal and create an
account for themselves we'll be giving
them a minute or two to do the same
let me also follow the steps
to assist you
if you click on the login button
you will be redirected to sign up on the
portal either by creating an account
yourself you can just simply put in your
details and create an account or you can
also log in by any of your social media
accounts
[Music]
thank you ashwini jamil and erandra for
quick response in the chat box
others who have also completed their
sign up please let us know in the chat
box so that we can proceed further
i see a lot many quick responses
so for those who have completed their
sign up on the portal
the next step for them is to complete
their profile so you need to click on
your mail address this will redirect you
to your profile tab where you need to
ensure that you have an updated profile
picture your social media accounts
should be connected and also add a brief
bio about yourself
it could include your educational
background and your research and trust
for every coursework that you complete
on the omixlogic loan portal you will be
getting the points that you can review
here that will take you from a business
level to an advanced level
and being a part of the bioinformatics
for infectious diseases program you will
be able to see a badge on your profile
tab that will ensure that you have the
access to the program page and the
resources associated
now before i hand over the stage to our
mentors to discuss more about the
curriculum
i would like to launch a poll for all of
you so that we can know uh
about you all your educational
background and your research interests
as well
i hope the poll is visible
oh just can you please confirm
yes yes thank you
so my first question here is what is
your educational background
are you a graduate
a post graduate
or a phd or a postdoc
what all are your research interests
from the options mentioned here
is it infectious diseases
oncology precision medicine agriculture
neuroscience or space omics
also what is your level of understanding
about bioinformatics for infectious
diseases
do you consider yourself to be at a
beginner
level or an intermediate or advanced
my fourth question is what type of
infectious disease data analysis do you
want to learn
is it ngs transcriptomics
or ngs metagenomics
or genomics or machine learning for ngs
data or structural biology data
and my last question is what do you seek
from this program
online infectious disease and data
analysis training only
or also a research component along with
the training
or mental guidance and one-on-one
support or would you like to work on an
independent research project
after the successful conclusion of the
program
we'll have the pool
on for more 30 seconds
thank you for the answers
if you have answered the point you can
make sure that you complete your profile
till then i'll just hand over the stage
to our mentors in 30 seconds from now
okay so now i would like to invite mr
ilya brodsky to please take over the
stage over to eurea
thank you very much malika are we going
to end the poll
yes i've done that okay
all right let me share my screens so
thank you everyone for joining today
it's exciting to be here this is one of
the programs that i think is very
relevant to what's going on all around
us so it's not unusual that we have so
much interest
let me briefly introduce why
bioinformatics for infectious diseases i
mean why do we need a special program
that is called bioinformatics for
infectious diseases how do we
think about infectious diseases compared
to other types of diseases and
conditions and then i'll briefly
introduce you to some of the challenges
that are still being a hot topic in this
area of research and then i will pass it
on to the mentors on the program that
will speak about some of the technical
aspects including some of the case
studies that we will use throughout the
program
so bioinformatics for infectious
diseases is a training program designed
to introduce students clinicians and
researchers to the role and the
applications of bioinformatics to the
study of pathogenic microorganisms and
their interaction with the host which
lead to and enable human disease
and our understanding of the
pathogenesis of these diseases can lead
to meaningful interventions
interventions like antiviral drug design
or maybe vaccine design we'll talk about
this in just a few more minutes
so in this webinar what we'll do is
we'll use some of the examples that are
case studies that we source from high
impact publications
and extract from their examples of
meaningful application of bioinformatics
methods of analysis to different types
of omics data including genomic data
transcriptomic data metadata genomic
data and others and so what i'll do in
my part of the presentation
is i will give you a glimpse of how some
of these different methods of analysis
are used and have been developed to be
applied to understand and intervene in
these kinds of diseases including some
of the additional challenges that are
still being researched and how we can
leverage the publicly available data
sets that are out there to be able to
ask these questions of
of
relevance and importance to what's
happening right around us
so the infection itself what is it and
why are we speaking about infectious
diseases as a whole category of
applications of bioinformatics so
infection is the invasion of an
organism's body tissues by
disease-causing agents there are
multiplication and the reaction of host
tissues to the infectious agents and the
toxins that they produce
so an infectious disease is also known a
as a transmissible disease or
communicable disease and it is an
illness that results from the entry or
the actual infection and replication of
that pathogen
so the infections that are caused by
infectious agents called pathogens or
include
viruses
as well as agents such as virus which
are not exactly viruses bacteria fungi
parasites
and then they are different from
non-infectious diseases which are also
recognized as chronic and can be caused
by such factors as the environment
nutrition lifestyle as well as genetic
inheritance so we typically think of
them as two separate categories but as
we will see today they actually have a
lot in common and one can be the result
of the other
so the replication of pathogens in the
host leads to major interference
starting from membrane disruption as in
the case with viruses and the release of
toxins as the case of many bacterial
pathogens maybe of these many of these
interferences include molecular
biological pathways that are designed to
fend off intruders and signal to
neighboring cells of danger the
pathogens can modulate these pathways
and cause long-term organ damage such as
lung tissue scarring due to the immune
hyperactivity so understanding of these
biological mechanisms
the way that the entry happens the way
that the body responds the way that the
viral and bacterial pathogens can
take and modulate those are all the
subject of bioinformatics for infectious
diseases because most of this
information comes from data
so let's take a look at some example
publications
to see
how
this has been monitored and studied
using different types of omics data
so the first example i want to bring up
is the outbreak of ebola virus that
happened in the
2014-2016 outbreak in west africa and
led to almost real-time genomic
surveillance of this disease
as a result genomic technologies were
shown to be effective and useful in an
outbreak of an epidemic
and led to significant interventions
like the discovery of antiviral
compounds and design of vaccines and so
as a result of genomic surveillance
better understanding of the disease and
intervention was a meaningful success
that shows how valuable genomic data is
and therefore bioinformatics which
allows us to study this kind of genomic
data and find meaningful insights in
this data
another example that i have here is an
example from stars cove two so obviously
living in the pandemic the role of
genomic surveillance allows us to answer
key questions about where did the virus
emerge from
how is it developing over time and how
can we anticipate future directions for
this viral replication and evolution in
order to be more effective at the types
of interventions that we can implement
including the testing of whether
standard interventions that we think are
effective or advanced interventions that
we might not think are effective at all
could be applied in a meaningful way to
contain this pandemic
another example that you can see here
is the genomic surveillance of
plasmodium fulcipro which is malaria
that is endemic in some areas of africa
and
still to this day after millions of
deaths
has not been uh addressed using new
vaccine so to understand this specific
pathogen genomic surveillance is being
used also to understand various factors
that lead to greater transmission
replication severity of disease and as a
result we can see how interventions are
being developed and tested that are
becoming more and more effective to
contain this disease
another interesting article that is
fairly recent is the increased
serological response against human
herpes virus 6a which is associated with
risk for multiple sclerosis this idea
has been proposed back in the 1990s but
only recently have there been validated
studies that show that indeed there is a
statistically significant association
between human herpes virus
and the development for multiple
sclerosis which leads us to think about
many other types of diseases that we
think are purely neurological or perhaps
genetic and
a result of somatic mutations like
cancer but in fact are caused by
different types of infectious agents
pathogens for example here are the seven
known viruses that cause human cancers
so an estimated 12 to 20 of cancers
worldwide are thought to be
resulting from tumor viruses so we're
not only speaking about in
diseases that can be monitored and
studied using omix data we're also
speaking about other diseases that we
haven't asked about what
caused through but those associations
are started to be
important to understand
so those were viruses what about
bacteria
bacteria are another pathogen some
bacteria could be pathogenic and
interestingly you can see this article
here that was
from 31st of january in 2022 the
staggering
toll of drug resistant bacteria which
talks about a global survey that shows
that in 2019 antimicrobial resistance
killed more people than hiv or aids or
malaria so not only do we see that
viruses parasites but also bacteria is a
major cause for global health
not only that we also see that drug
resistant tuberculosis poses a major
risk to global health security and we
all hear about antimicrobial resistance
in hospitals of new superbugs that are
not even known how to be treated so this
area of research is not only interesting
is not only relevance of the pandemic
that we're living through but it is also
a major direction for anyone who is
interested to apply bioinformatics
skills and data analysis skills to
address major challenges that we face
today and will continuously face in the
future
one of the interesting things about the
different pathogens that we discussed is
that naturally our body already has a
response to many of these infectious
pathogens
hosts can fight infection using their
immune system the mammalian hosts react
to infections with an innate response
often involving inflammation followed by
an adaptive response vaccines are used
to train the immune system to identify
pathogens and store the necessary
epitopes for antibody production in the
long term immune memory
but due to a variety of factors that you
immune responses can be insufficient on
their own
two main approaches that have
significantly reduced death from
infectious diseases in the past century
are the antibiotics antiviral drugs and
vaccines
in fact if we look at the timeline
we can see that the vaccines have been
discovered first but many other
ways to intervene have reduced
significantly the risk that infectious
pathogens
cause
or
pose so here you can see
from the 1900s all the way to 2000s this
is the rate of infection which is
per 100 000 population per year
you can see here simple interventions
for example uh
health departments establishment of
health departments or continuous
municipal use of chlorine in water in
the united states
you can see the um
kind of how specific diseases that we
think maybe are
you know well into the past have
actually not been so uh long ago so this
is the influenza the flu pandemic that
killed millions of people a plague
that was uh
last observed here in the 1920s
the use of penicillin if you think of
penicillin as something that was
you know discovered long ago you can see
that actually that was in the 1940s so
not that long ago and the first vaccine
that was introduced in the 1950s so all
of this is recent history this is the
history that many of us have
our parents go through our grandparents
group we know that these things have
happened very recently and a lot of the
developments that we are using today are
based on these kinds of interventions
but
over the
since we see such tremendous decrease in
these kinds of pathogenic diseases one
might think that well we've mastered
the way to train our immune systems and
protect ourselves from these pathogens
but in fact we see that
19 has proved all of us wrong
here you can see
this is a comparison to different other
causes of death and covet 19 surpassed
all of them which shows clearly that we
have not mastered the art of interview
of understanding and being able to
effectively intervene with these uh
different pathogens however what does
give us some promise so bioinformatics i
think is one of those disciplines that
allows us to be to stay
you know somewhat optimistic about the
future of infectious disease research
and the reason i say that is because
with covert 19 what we have seen is the
continuous application of biotics and
data science to
practical interventions that are being
used in real time and are being used to
adapt their response quickly to this
dramatic threat that we now understand
much better and we know how to intervene
much better as well what is
bioinformatics bioinformatics is the
intersection of computer science biology
and statistics and what i mean by that
is that we are able to apply
algorithms and software rely on
databases of different types of data and
use these data science skills to be able
to analyze data but this data isn't
meaningful unless we understand the
biological context and so the biological
context the specifics of infectious
diseases the pathways the different
pathogens the biology of the interaction
between the host and the pathogen all of
those are a critical component for us to
be able to
ask meaningful questions and find
answers that are significant and
relevant to the type of data now in the
middle of that our statistical and
machine learning or analytical skills
that we need
and those analytical skills primarily
are driven by our
new structure data and then ask
questions that are generalizable these
questions they're not only relevant to a
particular study they're relevant in
general to some biological phenomena
so one of the important things in the
context of infectious diseases is that
particularly in this area there has been
a dramatic increase in the number of
data size
data
databases and data types that are
available for infectious disease
research so here you can see this is a
slide from maybe a few months ago but
you can see here that the rate of
discovery of viral genomes the way that
these databases have become structured
and accessible is increasing
dramatically and that means that we can
start asking meaningful questions about
all of these types of questions that we
might have that we just learned about in
a fairly easy and user-friendly way and
so the purpose of training in the
context of bioinformatics for infectious
diseases is to start thinking how can i
ask an important question what kind of
examples can i follow and where can i
find data sets that provide me with
sufficient answers that i'm looking for
because even though so much has been
already done
not everything is clear in fact we know
that the diseases that are caused by
pathogens vary significantly between
individuals locations or even whole
populations
they happen at different speed at
different severity and the understanding
of how they happen is linked to a very
deep understanding of the immune
responses as well as the
evolution of these pathogens
and not only that we also are now
discovering that many of these viruses
and emerging pathogens are actually not
only
in individuals but they also are
in the environment they're all around us
they're in other animals and other
species and so we have to expand our
understanding of this molecular biology
to also be able to detect specific types
of
pathogens like viruses
in other environmental samples that we
might not have thought of yet and that
leads us to this major challenge of
annotation and curation of data to
understand relationships between strains
species and viola of different pathogens
and our ability to then understand their
function how do they function how do
they interact with the host
so in the context of this program one of
the key technologies that we're going to
be using and we're going to be talking
about a lot is next generation
sequencing
next generation sequencing could be used
in many different ways
it could be used to analyze individual
genomes like the covet 19 genome it
could be used to analyze meta genomes
where we have a collection of genomes in
a particular sample and we need to
understand diversity or maybe
relationships between these genomes
and also we need to understand the
different types of library preparation
techniques and steps to prepare the data
to make sure that we can answer specific
questions
now to be able to use this data we need
to understand the biology we need to
find the right kinds of data and then we
need to know a variety of techniques
that will make it easy for us
interpret and find meaningful
associations
and that includes
understanding of viral genomics and
evolution or phylodynamics how can we
build phylogenetic trees and monitor
progression over time connecting it with
temporal or maybe different types of
phenotypes that we have
understanding of transcriptomic data or
how to find differences in gene
expression and compare and contrast
different types of conditions or groups
of samples
variant calling where we can find
variants in specific positions of on the
genome and be able to interpret them
and analysis of
metagenomic data data that contains
thousands or even millions of different
microorganisms that need to be
categorized and
found relationships between them
the examples you i'm sure that you have
seen um you know in the news and
elsewhere but the examples that we will
use in this program
include
such epidemics like the ebola virus
which you can see right here
the understanding of
origins transmission replication
and development of continuous evolution
in this pandemic and how it affects our
bodies ability to respond to infection
and produce relevant immune responses
differentiating between specific
processes and stochastic processes
and then linking this understanding with
our ability to take a sample and monitor
the specific types of
clades and variants that are of concern
and ultimately being able to translate
this information
to report on our findings communicating
the results effectively with meaningful
annotation and interpretation
so to summarize what we will do in this
program is we will take a look at
different types of
omics data including genomic
transcriptomic and metagenomic data we
will learn to deal with these data sets
align them
find associations using different types
of processes
interpret them using our understanding
of structure and function of different
genes and proteins and then measure host
responses to really understand how does
the host respond to the different
infections that are there
now data
from next generation sequencing is very
complex this is an alignment of one of
the first sequencing data sets from the
soros cov2
samples that were identified in china
and so as you can see here it's not
trivial to get from this kind of complex
information to some meaningful insights
and so what we will try to do is we will
try to break it down to understand the
principles
behind the data that we have
the analysis methods that help us to
perform some of the functionality in a
semi-automated way
link that with biological understanding
of the processes that drive
the observed variation that we have in
the data and then use analysis methods
that help us
link those into meaningful models behind
the process that we think is driving
this variation
now ultimately we will also talk about
ways to interpret such data not only
find specific variation that is
meaningful but then also use the
appropriate route for interpretation and
we will use the different examples to
link this kind of sequence variation to
actual interaction and function of
different proteins that anyone can do
independently once you find the relevant
meaningful differences in your data sets
now to speak about specific examples of
how this type of bioinformatics approach
can be used to study viruses bacteria
and different types of
pathogens i want to invite our mentors
that will be helping you work through
these different case studies apply these
different technical methods and find
meaningful insights from relevant
biomedical publications i want to
introduce you to our mentors
dr raghavendran
is going to be your research consultant
and mentor he's going to be helping you
understand some of these topics and
guide you in the specific case studies
dr prio paul is going to be a teaching
assistant that will help you
understand any kind of technical issues
that you will have throughout this
training and dr mohit mizunder who's
also a project mentor and an expert in
computational biology who will talk
about how sequence and structure poses
some interesting insights and future
directions for this kind of research
so
dr ragov i want to invite you next to
talk about
some of the examples that we discussed
thank you thank you very much elia let
me find a way to share my screen and
yeah i hope my screen is visible to
everybody
yeah i also got a
confirmation hello everybody one more
time and i am raghavendran i'm a
research consultant and mentor with pine
biot economics logic i'm trained in
bioinformatics and i hold a phd in
computational biology from max plunk
institute of germany my broad research
interests include our my broad
resurgences are in the application of
data science methods to understand
cancer biology my role in
find biotech includes developing
curricula for the platform and also
mentoring students in the research
fellowship program and also in the
programs that you'll go to sign up
please allow me to talk about few
example projects that we have prepared
in the platform learn or mix logic
platform that will help you appreciate
how bioinformatics analysis can be
leveraged to understand the biology of
pathogens and to study infectious
diseases
so first we will focus on a project that
studies the current pandemic covid19 so
in this project we explored the
pathogens coronavirus itself and
as well as two diseases that that are
caused by it
so this project will help you explore
the origin of the pandemic and how
different diseases are caused by this
pathogen and how they are related to
existing strains from human coronavirus
and also
to other strains from animals
sources also so we will do this by using
publicly available data from
repositories like ncbi writers and
geo data et cetera
so we will learn in this project you
will learn to perform or how to perform
multiple sequence alignment followed by
palo genetic analysis these analysis
will help us compare the existing
strains of coronavirus to understand the
zoonotic origins of the disease so we
will also learn in detail how to
interpret results from
analysis like multiple sequence
alignment to understand mutational
changes in the genome of suspect ii
compared to different strains as i have
already told strains from humans and
also strains from different animals
next we will also see
what are the important protein
components of the virus through which
they enter into the human cell and we
will we will also learn how to visualize
the identified mutations on the spike
protein for example and from such
analysis and such visualization we can
understand and we can study which
mutation might affect the functional
properties of this spike protein and
alter its ability to bind to the
receptor in the host cell so furthermore
we will also
learn how we can look for
transcriptomics data from uh from
patients that are infected with cyscop2
using uh
public repositories like g gene
expression omnibus database and etcetera
here we will explore uh such data
this data in particular to find out
important transcriptional uh signatures
that are associated with drug treatments
like root solution
rucks in
short we will also learn some important
bioinformatics methods that are
available for identifying gene
expression signature for treatments like
rocks or axolotinet we will perform
differential gene expression analysis
between ruts treated and untreated
samples and we will also employ
unsupervised machine learning methods
like principal component analysis and
clustering to understand the potential
of these signatures
in categorizing drug treated and
untreated samples
so
yeah
during the course of this project you
will learn how to do and the logic
behind such analysis and how to
interpret these analysis in the context
of the
data or in the context of the biological
project or question in
so next project we will
get introduced to is on the outbreak of
enterovirus d68 or evd68 in short this
is a virus that causes a severe
neurogenic disease called acute flaccid
malates afm in short mainly in children
so it is a
in comparison it is a polio like illness
defined by the acute onset on
spine or on the paralysis of the spine
so in this project we will understand
the evolutionary relationship between
the strains of different outbreaks of
this virus so
to go into the history this virus first
emerged around 1960s and in the last
decade itself the outbreak of ebd68 has
been reported across different parts of
the globe even in developed countries
like united states
europe and
roughly once in two years or once in
three years or so on
so their pathogenicity also varies among
these outbreaks and among different
populations of these
virus
so similar to the sas project here also
we will use various phylogenetic
pre-reconstruction techniques and
algorithms to find out whether the ebd68
strains from different outbreaks at
different time points like 2014 16 18
are
from the same virus or from the same
strain or from the different strain or
related virus using
nixon sequencing data of the patients
so we will also see that phytogenetic
analysis reflects the variations in the
strain that causes these outbreaks in
different years or in different time
points furthermore
multiple sequence alignment will reveal
a number of variations in the sequences
of different viral strains a careful
analysis and how to perform this cash
flow analysis
will help us identify critical mutations
that can cause significant changes in
the amino acid level among these
different strains these mutations can be
related to the virulent properties of
the pathogen and will help us
characterize the viruses like evd68 or
sarskop2 which is currently
a very dangerous pandemic going on based
on their pathogenicity
hope that was informative and
that was very interesting and i look
forward to meet many of you in the
bioinformatics for infectious diseases
program i thank you very much for your
attention and and will now pass the
stage to dr priya
thank you very much
yeah hello everyone
just give me two minutes to share my
screen
so can you see my screen
yes family can see your screen
okay so i'm doctor priya
i'm a research and curriculum
coordinator at find biotech i did my
post doctorate from india instead of
science bangalore in uh molecular
biology and mathematics my phd is a life
sciences from gnd amritsar with
specialization in stress physiology and
i have 25 publications so far which are
published in journals of national and
international repute
regarding my
justice
[Music]
i'm sorry for the
interruption actually there was some
network connectivity issue regarding my
research interest
it is a next generation sequencing
cancer biology drug discovery and
repurposing stress physiology and data
science so i'll be talking about uh the
ebola virus outbreak so we all know
about the
2016 outbreak of ebola virus which
occurred in west africa and it affected
thousands of people all across the world
we all know that it is a viral disease
of humans and primates and it is caused
by ebola virus
so to develop the vaccines and antiviral
drugs for this infectious disease we
need to understand what is the origin of
this virus what is the shape and
structure of this ebola virus so
designed a project on this ebola virus
which is based on original publication
data to understand the origin and to
find out what are the important
mutations or the variants which cause
this lethal outbreak so we got the data
from ncbi platform ncbi virus platform
and we used genome sequence from this
particular platform and we performed uh
multiple sequence alignment and palo
genetic analysis to determine the
evolutionary relationship between these
genomes
and then we
what we identified was uh we identified
the groups of samples and so how they
are related to the phenotype so we use t
bio platform uh server which uh sonalica
and ilia and dr raghav they've already
spoken about this
so what we analyzed we analyzed
mutations between groups of samples
using comparative analysis to study the
mutability this method helped us to
identify the region of polymorphism
which is believed to cause an increase
in the ability of the virus to enter its
host cell
so this is called from my side and i'm
looking forward to
participation of all the
participants and
maybe coming the upcoming the research
fellowship program so thank you so much
over to use malik
thank you so much dr raghavendra and dr
priya now i would like to invite dr
mohairs to help us understand the
structure the program structure of
bioinformatics from infectious diseases
over to you dr mohit
thank you sunadika
am i audible
yes sir
okay so can you see my screen also sorry
for asking yes
no no it's perfectly fine yes we can see
us
hello everyone it's great to meet you
all today uh i'm mohit and i have a phd
in computational biology
and specialization in molecular modeling
simulations and discovery related
research projects
so in today's session
uh in a few slides
i'll go through the publicly available
data recent structural data from the
pandemic
so talking about that
the structural biology response to the
clovin 1910
to the kovid 19 panda pink has allowed
the world to see the virus how i mean
the virus is attacking us in us in a
structural uh
perspective so we can visualize we can
see the structure so it has also aided
in vaccine and therapeutic development
as and has shown four sides in the
investments in structural biology
capabilities in in you know techniques
such as um
such as external crystallography or
techniques such as cryo-em or the mx
so this sheer magnitude and uniqueness
of the event
that has you know uh
um that has enabled all of us in a way
that
that helped in all these different types
of data that has come out
from different repositories so today we
are going to get an overview of where
this data is and how it looks
so the speed with which these structural
inves investigations have occurred has
been really breathtaking similar
simultaneously the availability of these
data have
has benefited from the long history of
making you know these depositories and
the metadata that is also available uh
with this information about the
structural information and all of this
is available in repositories such as
protein data bank
a worldwide repository for
macromolecular structures and also we
are going to talk about some other
aspects of getting structure which is
through molecular remodeling so as the
one and there is like this one and a
half year since the declaration
of covid19 and
recently 1000 structures of starscope 2
biomolecules have been deposited in the
pdp itself so these are all experimental
structures that have been deposited in
protein data bank
so it is like kind of you know rare to
obtain a snapshot of such immense effort
in structural biology uh and uh this
happened due to this revolution of not
only uh
not only the need or the structures but
also the technology so with cryo-em
there's there has been a lot of you know
insights that we got from the
resolution revolution that is what it is
said in aspect of cryo-em microscopy
uh so uh talking about the computational
aspect of this so first the experimental
aspect is about the structural biology
events
and experiments that led to the
information of this kind of data that
how how these structures are but still
there are many limitations when we are
talking about the complete understanding
of how
it relates how structure can be related
to the function so there are uh that's
where i mean computational structural
biology a computational structural
bioinformatics comes in so where we are
talking about you know modeling complex
structures to gain insight or to be able
to understand the effect of mutations on
these experimental structures so those
things can be modeled and have been
playing a very important role in
understanding the pandemic more and more
and to find solutions so the source of
pandemic as i said
has contributed a lot in terms of also
uh structural biology work so in silicon
structural biology work so initially
initially what people were used to do is
i will tell you about some of the
software's that that are available
online tools such as the one that is
listed here
alpha full
but also there is a software that
many of us use for structural
predictions is a ci tester so from zen's
lab so it's a it's an online uh online
available tool and also alpha fold from
deepmind consortium
they have been able to with these two
rules we have been able to leverage
the uh gene relays release genomes
determine protein sequence and also to
create computational models and this has
been happening till the early march 2020
to till date so some modeling uh
a lot of insights that we could draw
from structural data is via modeling so
how do we model complex structures how
do models uh single point mutations or
multiple mutations and understand the
variance
and also uh then there is an aspect of
molecular dynamic simulations that have
massively also extended the utility of
experimental structural data that helps
in providing insights while the rapid
analysis of you know these in silico
mutagenesis for many key viral proteins
and also to the ability to for example
model glycosyl glycosylation of the
spike protein
our computational approach has also
helped in probing uh you know host
pathogen protein interactions so protein
protein interaction
uh and then contributing also in network
network based and machine learning based
analysis and we have an upcoming talk
about the network analysis uh tomorrow
uh that
i would
like uh you to all know about cyanx club
so we will be sharing that information
also with you
so about the structures and to
understand like what is available out
there and how to understand and make use
of this so that is an important aspect
of integrating structural biology into
your research or you know utilizing the
data that is available publicly so the
spy protein of this virus i mean uh
uh is one of the central figure right in
this fight
since it is the primary target for
antibodies to provide
and to target of antibodies that provide
immunity against the virus so the
surface of corona virus says i'll give
you a
layman explanation so the surface of
corona viruses are covered with these
spikes giving them their distinctive
clown-like appearances in the electron
micrographs so many people are already
aware of this and i think most of us are
so the spikes
the spikes initiate the process of
infection binding to the receptor and
then fusing with the cell membrane to
release the viral genome inside that's
the process so many other
and has been seen in many other models
as well like
influenza hematoglutinin and also hiv
and ebola so the spike protein is
composed you know of three identical
chains that form together a complex with
a small domain inside uh which is the
which is
inside the virus which is the membrane
spinning segment and there is a there's
a large ecto domain uh and that all you
can see some of those structures that
you can see in this
in this uh slide so this structures also
include a portion of
the many sugar chain that coats the
spike since the sugars are highly
flexible and difficult to observe that's
one of the challenges so many things
that you can gain inside from
is are the structures
are from the structures
and to tell you more about that so
recent structures have revealed that the
spike of star scope 2 and sasko
saskov and saskov 2. so comparing both
when you we compare both we we found out
that they are quite flexible so in these
structures the receptor receptor binding
domains
the receptor binding domain are seen in
the
um in different conformation so when you
compare structures and when you're
superimposing them on one of one another
in a three-dimensional space you can see
that differences and how there is a
movement you can find out about that
movement just from your you know screen
so by doing by learning about these
different tools that we will be covering
in this entire program so often just one
domain in this case of sas code two so
um many times what is happening is that
one domain you would see that there is
some movement and then
there are several other extensions that
that you will see that there are tucked
down or
i mean there are different type of
movements that have been uh found out in
these different types of confirmation
and then
researchers what researchers have
hypothesized that the recent scope to
where variants are virulent because
their receptor binding domains are
particularly flexible so that's one of
the hypothesis and whereas most spread
corona viruses that cause the common
cold are less
less dangerous because they are less
flexible so that's one of the hypothesis
that you can understand by comparing
some of the structures and understand
from the different conformations
that include uh the binding i mean to
understand this this has to be model so
you have structures from different
conformations that you obtain from
different protein data banks uh
structures uh which are
deposited online and then you try to
model them into a complex that will give
you a clear insight of how this is done
so these are some of the things that you
need to learn computationally in
computational biology or in silico
computational structural biology so
about the receptor binding uh our immune
system you know fight backs right when
coronavirus infects us so that's where
the antibodies comes in so antibodies
are what are protein molecules that play
a key role in any organisms defense
against a foreign molecule called
antigen right the first step in this
process is specific complex formation
between an antibody molecule and a
molecule of the antigen
so the structural basis of this antibody
antigen recognition is started to
getting illustrated from these
structures so these structures are
helping us to understand that mechanism
how it works
uh so the spike is a major target of
this protection right since it is
exposed to the surface of the virus
and these three protein i mean these
three protein uh structures that you can
see on the left which is 3bgf and 2g hw
and 6w41
and you can totally search them by their
four digital keyword to uh you just
paste them on your browser it will show
you to the link to the uh to their
actual structure that has been deposited
in the pdp so these are pdb ids
um so
these three structures um show that the
antibody can be recognized by spiked
proteins in many ways so two of these
antibodies block the receptor binding
portion of the domain but the other
antibody targets a cryptic site at the
base of the domain that is only exposed
when the antibody binds to it so you see
that there are not only just different
conformation but different active sites
also that you can find uh that you can
see which depends on the movement of the
protein so one thing that you have to
understand is that this is a pdb is just
a snapshot
and uh when a protein is in motion then
it is moving so there are different
conformations that are protein attends
and then based on those different
conformation there could be different
strategies to design molecule so this is
something that we should consider these
sort of structural information is
something that we should consider when
we go about you know
designing a vaccine or when we are
looking for strategies to find out
solutions to uh you know finding drug
finding a drug
so uh about this uh doing all of this is
kind of possible
so in this program we will be learning
to use powerful visualization tools such
as chimera
and explore through the available
structural data
and then also we will we will be
reviewing several tools developed for
your training in this program
uh to navigate large data sets and then
connect the various aspects of you know
various aspects of sequence structure
and metadata
into a single experience this is speak
nap
so what it will help us is that it will
help us in understanding or addressing
many questions so genomic data analysis
can be utilized to see the changes
between viral strains so you're looking
at the mutations and different
significance level of these detector
changes and how you track them or map
them to the 3d
position of the on the protein structure
so that you can see whether they are on
the surface whether they are in the
active site what could be the road
then
we will be using we will be able to do
you know from sequence to structure
another aspect is to do comparison and
that comparison at a sequence level is
could be done through multiple sequence
alignment so multiple sequence alignment
is a very powerful tool to understand
viral adaptation between animals and
protein and again then trace it back to
the structure
similarly another aspect of answering
some of the research questions
would be to
understand the relationship between
virus viral and post
host proteins such as the trimeric sauce
coronavirus surface surface spike glycol
glycoprotein
so this spike glycoprotein
binds to a cellular receptor called
angiotensin converting enzyme to so ace2
i mean you might have like you might all
i've heard about is to in short so and
it mediates through the fusion of viral
and cellular membranes through a pre to
post fusion conformation translation
transitions so as i was telling you
before also so because of certain
binding there are trans uh you know
there are conformational changes that
enables another binding event so all of
this fascinating stuff and
you and and just imagine to be able to
visualize it and to understand from
sequence level to a structural level is
something that we are planning for this
program and
we're hoping that many of you can go
through that experience and understand
different aspects of how structure
and complexes
that mapping mutations
from a single protein from a population
to the three-dimensional structure and
understanding the function obviously is
something that we're trying to um help
uh everyone to learn
so this is what we have planned for the
structural part and that's what i wanted
to tell you all about in today's session
and uh we will be covering these these
in much more detail when we go through
this these different case studies that
will be covered covered in the full
training program uh starting from 14
february and
that's about my part of the presentation
and uh
to tell you more about the entire
schedule of this program and how the
sessions will be and how you could all
register i'll now hand it over to uh
minnesota
thank you so much dr mohit for such a
wonderful presentation
now i would like to take you all through
uh the registration page to get yourself
enrolled for the program commencing on
14th of february
and this is the link to the program page
i'll be pasting it up in the chat box
also we'll be mailing out the
link to the program page along with the
link to the recording of the session to
you all after the session
so once you are here on the program page
you will find all the details that are
related to the program that includes a
program overview and most important of
all the schedule for the program
so here you will find all the session
dates and also the sessions let me just
zoom in sorry
yes here you will be able to find all
the session dates along with each and
every topic of the session and also the
topics that are supposed to be covered
in the sessions along with the
associated online resources so for each
and every session uh there are some
online associated resources that
includes the links to the lessons on the
army logic learning portal and also some
mental guided resources that you will be
supposed to go through along with each
session
once the session is completed once each
session is completed we'll be sending
you about the link to these associated
resources and also the recorded sessions
in case you miss out on the session or
uh want to revise the session you will
get the recording as well as the
associated resources and publications
that are to be followed along with the
session itself
now when you scroll down on the program
page itself you will find three levels
two uh like which you can refer to
enroll yourself for the program
the first level is a beginner level
which includes the access to live q and
a sessions group sessions and also the
recordings
the access to almost logic load portal
and the t bio info server educational
pipelines then we have an intermediate
level
which will give you an access to
one-on-one mentor support and then we
have an advanced level where you will
get some extra time to figure out a
research proposal with the help of the
mentor you will be able to
explore some of the data sets from the
big data repositories and you'll be able
to come up with a research proposal that
you can further work upon
in the research fellowship program and
get yourself a publication
or
at least present your your research work
in a poster presentation uh format that
is in the upcoming symposium that is
scheduled for march 31st and april 1st
so these are the three levels beginner
intermediate in advance that you can
opt for and you simply need to click on
the sign in and checkout button and you
will also be uh given the access to the
early bird discount coupon code via
emails i believe so our marketing
executives firsthand will send you a
market um
a coupon code that will give you the
access to the early bird offer with
which you you can definitely enroll in
the program picking up any of the levels
that you would like to enroll for
and when you scroll down
you will also get the list of program
course and project library that includes
the associated coursework that you are
supposed to go through as a part of the
program which includes our mislogic
courses and example projects which will
help you understand how the key concepts
methodologies and the pipelines that you
went through could be applied to answer
a real life research problem and get
some hands-on practice
and yes definitely many of you had a
question about the certification process
so once you successfully complete the
program you will be accredited with the
certificate
and
this was the like this was all the
information that was required for you to
know about the registration process and
we have the link shared with all of you
now if anyone of you has any questions
please put them up in the chat box so
that we can answer
[Music]
okay so mohammed is
asking is there any program on analyzing
cancer data
i would like dr mohit uh to take this
question specifically because i think
he's the best person to answer it uh
nicely what are your doctor
okay so dr mohit i think he's not here
yes so when you say cancer data
specifically you are uh referring to the
oncology field right so yes we
definitely have a lot of programs uh
that includes the uh analysis and the
understandings first of all and then
definitely to get some hands-on practice
with this type of data so when you say
cancer data or let's say the oncology
field then comes the role of either
transcriptomic data analysis or genomic
data analysis that you can go through
and learn about right but even
metagenomic data analysis could be
explored and learned about as we have
had recently a lot of publications are
telling how metagenomics
data could be explored to understand the
plant uh the patterns that are
responsible for causing a cancerous
condition
so yes so when you say oncology then we
have three programs specifically that is
genomic data analysis metagenomic data
analysis and also the transatomic data
analysis
and having the knowledge of these
particular skill sets you can definitely
apply these uh skill sets to the
specialization track of oncology and
mohammed
recommend you if you can just simply put
your mail id in the chat box and uh
you'll get the list of these programs
that you can explore you like you can
see what all uh
topics these programs includes and what
exactly would you like to explore and
learn from and get some hands-on
practice so just put your main id and
we'll be able to help you out with that
omovami is asking how many session how
many hours uh are the session and the
time please
so um the
like the sessions will be uh an hour and
a half each though they are scheduled
for an hour but uh because we have
discussions with the program
participants definitely it gets extended
to an hour and a half or maybe two at
max and these sessions are scheduled for
9 00 am cst you can convert it to your
time zone and see what exact time it
becomes
and
also let's say you are not available at
9am cst and you're not able to make up
to the live session then you can
definitely go through the recorded
session and take up your questions in
the slack channel so we have slack
channel for each and every program that
we have and you can take your questions
in the slack channel you will also have
the mentors up there and uh
follow the
recordings specifically in that way
and uh for the session schedule please
refer the program page here you have all
the dates listed
and also you have all the topics listed
for each and every
date
uh dr raghavendran you are here with us
right
we have a specific question that i would
uh like you to address
the question is by saurabh roy he's
asking i would like to ask if there is
any blockchain based technology
available for bioinformatics or any
in development
oh
that's a toughy
i mean